to start with a silly fun question how
long did it take you guys to learn and
actually get the title right
because i feel like sometimes i just
keep calling the show the woman in the
house across the street from the guy
that also lives there because it feels
like any variation kind of works but
did you have to practice to get that
right
i got it right right away and i that's
not a brag that's because it felt like a
wonderful joke and i think when someone
does a really good bit or makes a really
good joke that's just tonally perfect it
i tend to remember it i feel like this
title really lets the audience know that
we are we are going to be making fun of
things and this might not be as serious
as they think michael and tom how about
for you guys like when you explain this
show to your friends or family
do you get the title right
i mean
yeah and i don't know if it's it's
because i mean i guess i have practice
because i've said it more than some
people would say but i explaining that
title there's a real there's like a a
little joy to being able to say oh
that's what i'm shooting and that's
what's going to be on soon the woman in
the house across the street from the gun
on the window because you see people
think that the title should have ended
it should have ended five seconds ago
and you're still going and there's
there's a joy in that for sure
the title is definitely tied into the
experience right having lived through
this experience of making this project
you kind of think
that's it
i mean you could even probably add more
like
it is
it is such a such an appropriate title
for this experience that i think the
viewers will have
the title is too much and the show is
too much exactly and that's why it works
because titles are supposed to to be to
economize language
to let you know just a tiny little hint
of what you're about to get into and we
tell you almost everything and we tell
you mostly non-pertinent details about
the show in the title that's kind of why
the whole bit works
when you all learned who the actual
killer is and you read the script and
you saw how it all plays out
what was your reaction and and how do
you think viewers are going to react
i
could never in my wildest dreams and i
spent a lot of years playing a detective
on television um i
could never have guessed that this is
how they would have ended it but it
feels perfect
i i think the most shocking thing was
how violent the ending got
from my perspective
tom what about you i mean how did you
react to learning how things would end
up
i mean i i i love the end it feels
it feels perfect for what the show is
while at the same time being completely
unexpected and like like kristen said it
was incredibly violent and i was there
for the violence i didn't do anything
about it but it was it was um
there was some brutal stuff going down
michael was there anything that you were
particularly surprised about was it just
the ending that surprised you were there
moments along the way that surprised you
was it a lot of oh my god i can't
believe this is where they're taking
this yeah there's a lot of oh my god
this is where we're going like there it
was it was a roller coaster ride from
the moment i read
you know the scripts i mean i i was just
having these laugh out loud
moments in these big gasps every time i
read this you know the scripts and so
you know they're they just they didn't
feel like they had limits you know the
writers really felt like they they
didn't have any limit
to how absurd or how outrageous they
were going to make a situation to be and
it was it was a joy to actually see them
kind of push the boundaries especially
with this particular genre i was so
impressed with how this show takes on
everything with these types of stories
from the wine to the rain to the attic
all of the misdirection
adding in grief and a love story i mean
just everything is in this and somehow
it manages to all work
were you ever worried that you were
taking on too much and throwing too many
things into the mix or was everybody
always giving suggestions for things to
add i mean i certainly didn't give
suggestions to add anything because
these writers you know larry hugh and
rachel
um who i've known for a while they're
trained groundlings they're trained
writers they're they're very very good
at what they do and rachel has read and
watched every psychological thriller
ever and is particularly interested in
the ones that are written by women for
women and what that entails and so i
didn't add anything but i actually felt
like unless they went for broke and like
michael said were completely uninhibited
about what kind of absurdity they would
throw at you and unless they made fun or
commented on everything in this genre it
wouldn't work
this is a show that we had to we we
acted with subtlety but nothing about
the world of the show is subtle it's all
very in your face
kristen
you also got to do the final scenes with
the wild cameo that everybody will talk
about by the end of the show
what was it like to shoot that
especially with who you got to shoot it
with it felt like
uh the psychological thriller gods were
blessing us
because the the queen of all
psychological thrillers
um
having put
effort into even reading the email with
the invitation to be a part of this
was so thrilling and and
it almost allowed uh it made me feel
safe to poke fun at this genre knowing
that she gave it her blessing michael
what was it like to explore this
relationship but the relationship
between your characters is
serious it's dramatic it's sad i mean
what was it like to
really kind of have all of that drama in
the middle of all this craziness
you know i've had my fair share of of
love stories that i've that i've
participated in and there was none
there was never one that was like this i
mean this one just had so many more
layers to it it had so many more
um just uh
twists and turns and
you know trauma quite honestly like you
know this this relationship was rooted
in trauma and so in a lot of ways it was
uh much more complicated and as
christian was saying earlier the most
complicated part of it was the tone you
know being hopelessly in love but also
kind of
kind of an idiot about it you know what
i mean like love can make you an idiot
and that that's how i felt douglas was
in a lot of ways
tom your character is someone that we
learn about through the relationships
that he has with the women in his life
from his dead wife to his neighbor to
his girlfriend
his daughter
what was it like to explore
each of those
relationships and and find the character
through all these different sides to him
because he sort of feels like a
different person with each
person in his life
well i think that's partially because a
lot of what you're seeing is anna's
perspective of him and so he has to
she is constantly remaking in her mind
who the man is whether he is the great
hope that she's been waiting for her
life or whether he's a murderer and she
she bounces back and forth and some of
those relationships that you see you're
not seeing the truth you're saying
how um anna is imagining it so yeah it's
very much about playing the role that is
simultaneously the man he is the man i
know he is but it's all revealed in
episode four and
at the same time trying to play the guy
that's anna's invention
kristen i i absolutely love the
character of people because i i also
love cameron britain
it's hilarious and insane that he pretty
much exists just to fix a mailbox which
kind of makes him the worst handyman
ever
so how much fun was it to have that
dynamic as really sort of the only
constant that runs throughout this whole
show
it was
a lot of fun because not only was it the
constant but it was the usually when
there's a constant you know when there's
a wise old tree in a cartoon you go back
to the constant you get new information
buell's character gives absolutely no
information
or is not helpful in any way he's just
the constant and so anna doesn't really
know where to place him other than like
he's just always there and then as the
story unravels and you you know there's
this wonderful line that i have to
michael's character when i say um
what was buell like when you hired him
to fix our mailbox all those years ago
and just that line it kind of sums up
what we're doing like oh and you go oh
my god he's been fixing that mailbox for
years and if you really watch cameron's
performance he's so great because he's
just he's picking things up and he's
looking at them and he's that's my to-do
list he's picking things up and he's
like just a screwdriver he analyzes
everything before he touches it it's
great and it's absolutely pointless
which is perfect
yeah i loved everything about it i loved
this show i had such a blast watching it
and
really kudos to all of you for pulling
this off because it's it shouldn't have
been able to be and it is so thank you
thank you